[Music]
right yesterday the Orange County
Sheriff's Office announced that they
will reject California's sanctuary laws
and actually help ice agents and enforce
federal law we sent our own Tommy Lehren
to Orange County - residents what they
think of the undersheriff in this move
take a look so I can tell by your shirt
that you're probably pretty excited
about the Orange County Sheriff who's
making the list of inmates criminal
inmates available upon their release
making it easier for ice to do their job
I support the enforcement of law and I
want to see that happen that's that's
important thing to our community we
should do as much as we can to find out
you know certain kind of criminals that
are here illegally that they should
follow off it's a bad idea I think being
a sanctuary city you know we're supposed
to protect you know each other and we're
supposed to build bridges I believe in
building bridges and not walls you know
I think we should be paying our
immigration officers to do probably more
to go ahead and do their job bit better
well then what about making it easier
for them to find criminal illegal aliens
that are had a prison yeah extremely
easy to do that yeah I guess if they're
violent sure but what if you know you
got to take it crossing the street like
jaywalking or something and and you know
coming out of jail though I mean that's
not really a Jimmy you can go to jail
for all kinds of things here I have
unpaid traffic violations you're gonna
you're gonna like jail all right most
people have that many unpaid traffic
violations I mean are the people you
want living in your country that I mean
it have no legal right to be here in the
first place most Californians do not
want California be a lawless sanctuary
state they want to be protected they
want the laws enforced joining us live
from Orange County California Fox News
contributor Tommy Lehren Orange counties
not California
aye Orange County's a little bit of a
more conservative area but if they go
after this sheriff this is where it gets
serious and you heard the Attorney
General today I wonder does that then
mean that the that the Oakland mayor
that was aiding and abetting criminal
illegal immigrants by telling them that
there was they were going to be arrested
and and giving them an opportunity to
get away is now they're going to be
reciprocity this could be an all-out
battle
I think if the citizens of California
wherever they are honest with themselves
they want to be safe and secure in the
state of California and again talking to
people on the streets today that's what
you heard this is this community
although it is somewhat conservative in
Orange County where we're where we are
in Santa Ana this is an immigrant
community as well there are a lot of
immigrants here some of them illegals
some of them legal and the legal
immigrants that I spoke to although they
want what's best for their fellow
immigrants they believe in the rule of
law they want to be safe in their
community because they feel that they
are Americans that's what I heard today
and remember the president said I want
to build a big wall on the southern
border with the big door but just asking
people to do illegally well I think that
that's what I've been asking people for
weeks now in California and they agree I
think that the left has just dominated
this conversation about the wall and
it's become just a talking point at this
point but if you really break it down
people want security they want safety
they want a the immigration process to
be reformed they want common sense and
the wall is common sense it's just the
left has dominated this conversation and
they've made the walls some kind of a
demon object and it's not it's for the
safety of Americans all right Tommy
thanks so much for doing that a great
job tonight